there's a new podcast out each week this
man talks to a celebrated wide receiver
and about their career journey life and
everything in between new episodes of
wr1 drops every single thursday chris
carter pro football hall of famer back
here on the rich eisens show
mercedes-benz vans phone line how are
you sir
rich i'm doing very good i have to
apologize i'm in new york city yes i
know i'm trying to get i'm trying to get
my covert card replaced because you
can't go anywhere without one here right
so i'm out of cvs it might be a little
noisy so not as professional as i'd like
to be oh good thanks for having me on
the show i also saw that you were on
good morning football today i saw that
i peeped that as the kids say um so that
that looked like fun
for you and everyone i mean talking
football i mean why wouldn't it be fun
got a game tonight had an exciting week
number one leading into
to a great week number two so yes it was
a good day okay now um uh you know i
appreciate your your you're in the cvs
getting your card replaced
uh but let's let's talk a little bit of
ball right here uh uh after week number
one
your most impressive uh performance uh
of any wide receiver in week one would
be what
which one do you like
wow of any wide receiver yes sir which
one would you like most impressive
well i'm just gonna can i say this yes
sir
waller's a great player but he's not the
best player i've ever seen compared to
john gruden but he's
right
but waller had a heck of a week there's
no doubt about that that's true well i
was really excited though that the guys
because we're getting a lot of guys
drafted in the first round and it's
really hard to have success last year we
saw justin jefferson that's not going to
be every year but it's nice to go see
devonta smith jaymar especially after a
bad preseason jaymar chase there with
the bengals
bust up my vikings have a good game
against them and then wado in miami like
these coordinators are figuring out a
way to go get these young guys involved
in the game and having fresh wide
receivers in the game good ones um it's
good for the game and what happened
what's going on do you think with
brandon ayuk i mean you you've you've
been there you've done that you've heard
what coaches say publicly you know what
probably goes on behind the scenes um
what do you think is going on with san
francisco's receiver and the coach
saying essentially that you know he's
hurt but he you know that's part of the
reason why he hasn't gotten enough snaps
and you got to be appreciably better
than the guy behind you uh or the guy in
front of you what do you think
is happening one they got a talented
roster
and in the nfl man if you're not putting
up the numbers and everything regardless
of where you're drafted eventually
they're going to be able to find you out
and we know
kyle well enough that if the guy was
making plays he would be out there and
you have to trust what people they sit
and watch hundreds hours of tapes they
go to all these practices you know i
really listen to what the coaches are
saying
so what happened there is
the receivers put the coach in a
position that he's got to build say
things like that because he didn't have
anything good to say
you know so ultimately the transition
from being a good college wide receiver
so he's really good with the ball on his
hand
to trying to be a refined route runner
things like that that's where we start
losing and that's what i think coach
shanahan was trying to tell us without
telling what do you think julio jones is
thinking after his coach calls him out
uh in week one and a blowout loss in his
new spot
for um a
penalty a 15-yarder that cost his team
in the first quarter of eventually a
blowout game what do you think julio's
thinking about his coach vrabel right
now
you know julio welling
julio is not the typical y receiver
julio
top five coming out of high school five
star best receiver the top five talent
chose to go to alabama but nick saban
and let me tell you something his tenure
there because i know nick
he didn't he never asked for an easy way
there was no harder worker in practice
in the games couple times he was hurt
they had to keep him out
so julio has heard everything
and to me the best players that have
played this game they want to be coached
up
and that helps the titan
because if ravel can chew out julio
jones he can chew out a bunch of people
and i'm sure they had a bunch of
bad plays i mean the left tackle didn't
play good either so that's not the only
person he was cussing out but who julio
he's not the typical wide receiver i'm
sure he brushed it all i'm sure rabel
said something to him personally
he didn't leave it up
for all that error between what he said
to the media because he knows the media
is going to go back to helio so he's a
grown man he goes talk to julio lets him
know and a lot of times in a situation
like that dennis green would tell you
before the meeting
i'm going to call you out in front of
everybody like okay
what do you mean and it really sets the
temperature for the team and and for
what their expectations are give me that
story dennis green would do what come on
now really he'd tell you like this what
i'm going to do i'm going to call you
out so be careful you know be ready for
it well i i used to
meet with him on a weekly basis
so
he'd always write the report on the team
how's the locker room doing
and
just like belichick putting brady in the
bad place dennis green would put you in
the conversations as far as if that's
what he wanted to do that's where he
would put his star players in
chris carter here on the rich eisen show
my hall of fame friend sitting there in
new york city after he did some good
morning football and you got your
podcast wr1 each week so
um so this pod
is it wide receiver one or wr1 what are
you calling it chris it's wr1 okay all
right wide receivers only i mean you you
know you've been on the podcast world
how am i going to create a niche so for
me it's just talking to
the most exciting position
the personalities are across the board
through the last several decades so for
me i just thought that
being a former wide receiver getting
their perspective on life playing the
game what forced them to the position
all those things what we talked about
well the question is is so wide receiver
twos and threes are not going to be in
the invite list only wr ones
chris
it's like
you know like so
yes alvin harper no like is that
basically the way it's gonna go no no
it's not by
one two or three no no no this is season
one
oh
okay
wr1
wide receiver two okay
got it understood and under a very very
healthy response from the public there
will be a wide receiver too
[Laughter]
all right i'm going to continue on with
this with this line of questioning
because chris chris
chris can handle it chris can handle it
because i thought it was just wr1 so
only wide receiver ones
were allowed on so i was going to ask
you if if that was the case would you
have been allowed on the podcast when
randy moss
was with the vikings
chris carter
rich
[Laughter]
yes no matter what rule you have no
matter what law you have you need to
have some addendum to the rule yes
now they're going to be occasions where
you're going to have two number ones on
the field
before we got randy moss in minnesota
jake green myself had compiled
four consecutive thousand yard seasons
both of the nfl records before we got
randy moss
moss just kept the party going man we
did another three so i had seven years
in a row where the other guy across from
me had a thousand so
what would you make of that
oh that sounds like a wide receiver one
to me you know i just was
you know i'm just
i was just wondering you know about the
velvet ropes you've placed around your
guest list here for your pod because i
mean you got calvin you got mike evans
you know those are clearly wide receiver
ones um
what did you talk about with calvin i
mean what a fascinating hall of fame
speech i heard from him we all heard
from him back in august yeah chris
what'd you talk about with calvin i mean
calvin's a smart guy i mean he's got a
great deal of interest of course we
talked about the detroit situation and
it really just boiled down to respect
about the money he felt like there were
a lot of games he went out there hurt
injured didn't say anything
and when he decided to walk away
because medically he felt like he
couldn't continue i mean he's from a
family of doctors like all his relatives
aunts and uncles and stuff are doctors
and stuff he thinks he's he's the dummy
in the family
and when he just said that he just
it hurt his pride
because he knew what his body was
enduring
um
that probably robbed him of another
three to five years claimed that we as
fans would have been able to see calvin
johnson we talked about the medical
marijuana business that he's involved in
yes and more of assisting people for
pain not for recreational use but the
science behind it uh concussions how
potentially it can assist in things like
that very very good conversation
problems one that
guys no matter what era you look at he's
one of the people that you respect play
the game the right way lives the right
way been a great role model great
spokesperson for the game well i was
sitting there with uh my buddy steve
weich my nfl media group colleague steve
watch on the set listening to that
speech and we were just looking at each
other nodding our heads about how
terrific it was and the points he was
making about you know
medical marijuana and how it could be
used in a way that is not allowed in so
many different places because it's being
thought that it's just
a workaround for recreational use and
then when the speech was over we both
looked at each other and and said there
was one
mention missing from the entire speech
and it was the detroit lions he did not
yeah say the franchise's
team
name once
in that speech
we we didn't i don't think we missed it
and we heard i mean that was that was an
outlier for the entire there were 19
speeches that weekend and i think it was
the only one where somebody didn't
mention the team that he played for a
single time
chris i mean it's that's your moment
and for him
he's not shying away from the subject
um he's not happy with detroit he
doesn't have an existing relationship
with them right now
and it's all over
money i think he made a statement said
1.6 million dollars make me feel better
so
you know when
when you have a player it's your
responsibility especially when you're
drafting top five top 10 which detroit
is doing done for a while and these guys
have played the game done things the
right way you're supposed to take care
of them away not i'm not saying all
players should be settled but the
relationship with detroit and calvin the
only team that he knows it should be
better than what it is
yeah well look chris uh that i i look
forward to hearing uh all of these
conversations on your new pod episodes
here every single thursday including
today wr1 uh can you tell cvs to turn
the music down i mean my god sounds like
you're in a katy perry concert there hey
man we're trying to get people
vaccinated yeah we're getting covered
okay like it's gonna do it right i'm in
the most i'm in the quietest spot in the
tv
all right i'll let you go but i do want
to ask you a trivia question first chris
you ready for this trivia question
okay
my guys are know it's coming and they're
they're they're hiding underneath the
the they're hiding underneath right now
no no it's okay we go way back this man
i understand we go way back okay you've
heard about the historical alliance
right in college football between the
big ten
and the acc and the pac-12 right chris
yes okay
which school in the big ten came up with
the first win in the history of the
historical alliance when one
member of
the historical alliance like say the big
ten played another like say the pac-12
which school did that first for the big
ten
i mean it was on your show i don't have
any clue
i mean
i mean we lost oregon but things are
still exciting
somebody can run for 200 yards we are
going to have you okay
we are going to yeah since you brought
it up yeah sure all right okay you tell
me something i got a trivia question
this wins between
the wolverines when they played the
buckeyes in the game
how many days has it been
it's close to 700 days before you start
looking
yeah
you're breaking up chris i don't know if
the reception's any good in the cvs
[Laughter]
it's been it's been a long time man it's
in the thousands bro
this
it's in the thousands bro might be my
favorite line that i've had thrown at me
by you chris um hey man hey look uh you
be safe and i i want to thank you here
cause i don't know if you've been on
since then but you and um your time that
you gave for the run the charity run um
for run rich run at sofi
and uh i will say this and it's not just
because i was busting your stones uh
moments ago
even though you busted mine back but um
you you know i mean vic ran one really
fast but lost amongst that was you
uh not only running one damn near sub
five but you were one of the few that
could have gone again if necessary
because everybody else was not
at that time you crushed it chris carter
you're doing great things and a lot of
times people try to reinvent the wheel
come up with another foundation but when
people are doing stuff like you're doing
why don't we just piggyback and help
support what you're doing so that's what
we decided to do you're a great guy been
doing great work for a while and
it's not your fault you went to michigan
you know it's not your fault
so for me i got in a little trouble when
i was earlier so i'm still doing
community service so every time i work
with you it's just community service
i appreciate that chris carter
let's talk more let's talk more be safe
go get your uh go get that card again
and uh and wr1 every week including
today new podcast with chris talking to
only the finest at the position let's do
it again soon chris you'll be well i
appreciate it richard you guys chris
carter everybody right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here